Hello friends welcome to top five Skyrim
mods of the week I'm cam this is Seb and
it's good to have us both back in the
Skyrim seats it's good to have me back
it's it's good to get rid of Lucy J no
she's been great we love you Lucy she's
she's effective I mean yeah she she's
like a she's a welcome substitute but
she's like that player a welcome
substitute player who not quite as good
as the main guys she's the person that
you put on the last five minutes of the
game so they get have a run around go
stretch your legs a
little I helped anyway anyway Seb hey
you know what's exciting uh what is
exciting cam Skyrim mods is going to
change a little bit but wor change I ha
change a good kind of change we're still
going to have our five mods it's going
to be much the same we're just going to
throw in a few extra things and ways
that you guys can get informs for
example Seb yeah what we're going to
start next week well what we're going to
do is at the beginning of each show
we're going to add a little fan feature
and what that's going to be is a
Showcase of our favorite thing that
you've sent in it could be something
that you've done in Skyrim a screen grab
of your character doing something a bit
weird or wonderful um or maybe if you've
spotted something in real life that
reminds cuz you guys send us loads of
great photos and we want to like find a
way of showcasing like the best one we
get each week right at the top of the
show so everyone's still like watching
cuz not everyone watches to the end and
that's fine but at the beginning
everyone is we want to like really show
that off so that's one thing we're doing
that's our business strategy yes we're
very clever uh the other thing we're
going to start doing and this is a great
idea which is kind of riffing off a
suggestion we had from a Skyrim Watcher
named cat Jones so thanks for your idea
but this what we're going to do is start
a Kevin Van Nord Choose Your Own
Adventure so brilant what we need you
guys to do is every week you need to
submit like what happens next basically
so to start it off if you want to take
part you need to send us the like intro
sentence we don't have a start so we
need that to begin and then what we can
do is in the same way that we do the
vote on a straw pole we can choose our
favorite three four five um suggestions
of what happens next and you guys can
vote and you guys you guys choose on it
you will literally be choosing Kevin Van
nord's Adventure exactly and then every
week following we'll need an update on
what happens after that so fantastic
it's going to be brilliant and the final
new thing that's going to happen this is
exciting if you live the most exciting
if you live in the UK we are in the
midst of planning and we can finally
start talking about it a live
top five scar mods of the week that's
not just a twitch live not just twitch
like live as
in live in a room in a probably a pub in
London somewhere at some point before
the year is out that's our goal by way
of tweets yes the best kind of thing we
can get for a show of hands would
anybody be interested in coming to one
of those if we you live in the UK and
ideally London and you be interested in
coming along tweet us so we can get a
rough idea of how new people would
actually come along yeah cuz if it's
just me Seb and seb's Mom while we'll
have a great time look she is the top
Skyrim fan you know she is our number
one fan she is uh that would be great
but it'd be great to have a few more
people there as well all right that's
enough new stuff on with the
show b s it's a be that means it's time
for mod number one careful Kevin's
allergic cting them one B one mod now
this mod is nothing to do with bees
nothing at all I like your little Sesame
Street reference by the way did not go
unnoticed this is a true wolves of
Skyrim that's not a wolf so long be I'll
let that bee continue its life we're
hoping to get true bees of Skyrim real
soon that was a large bee they should be
smaller than that so if you want to make
true bees of Skyrim I'm on
board right on command and that is
definitely a new wolf texture get get
get all Zoomi let's have a look at him
yeah oh man he's beautiful I kind of
don't want to kill him he's gorgeous the
problem is like by making him look more
High rest rock rock joint damn you
beautiful wolf oh oh sorry God I'm so
sorry just I just tried to push him away
I was petting him I swear these new
highdea wolves are so weak and ply
Unfortunately they also have up the
adorableness of them like you
[Applause]
said that is different Hello Wolf Pelt
that looks that is also more
adorable it's like a skateboard I wonder
if we can ride it down the M ride it
down the
mountain like theidea that maybe you
could like let it float off on the water
and it look like a little furry
alligator oh I totally would let's give
that a go Wolf Pelt boat go y it works
it works it totally worked wolves Seb
not just wolves a family of wolves of
multicolored wolves wolves ice wolves
you know what they're they're very
adorable who are you who are you a thief
a thief get him wolves get him yeah wait
the thief is killing all our wolves I'll
get her no the wolf is killing all our
thieves is that the old orc it is the
old orc dead or no that's my best my
best execution when you install it it's
another one of those ones on the Nexus
mod manager which brings up a a prompt
that gives you options of you know oh I
want the really really white ones or I
want the slightly grubby white oh so
there's lots of different options yeah
tons of different ones look at
him he Smiley little guy ad horrible I
must kill my own spirit
animal these are all of his conflicting
story lines that you will choose later I
feel quite bad about this I must say Oh
no just don't feel bad about okay feel
bad about that that was really that was
really awful that killed that one
standing up that's very neat that is
just a pile of of adorable
[Music]
death yeah I definitely had nothing to
do with this either there's actually an
extra bit in this as well oh what's that
upstairs must be upstairs must be I hear
you pal I'm coming oh
there what we have an invisible dog I
think okay that's obviously not quite
worked this is quite this is quite
creepy he's right there kill
it
oh that's awful oh I hate it oh it's
awful I don't like this at all oh this
is the worst mod ever this might be the
worst thing you what what you mean not
me it's Kevin jeez oh I think he died if
we ever managed to spawn Lola in and
find out exactly how adorable time to
leave s
oh
all right guys welcome to mod number two
and this is called Jackson's renamer
yeah we've done Jackson's positioner
before because Jackson's positioner was
awesome and the renamer looks like it
could be even more so so basically just
lets us rename anything yes such as you
renamed this gift for me this is now a
freedom flower because I wanted it to
represent something more than just what
it stood for in your heritage cam the
thing I really want us to do is go back
to Solitude and call everyone won
Jerkins hello there here it's Jerkins I
believe it's
Jerkins hi
Jerkins oh my God it's this guy oh it's
it's our old friend not J it's but
Jerkins
jerk yeah that's good hey ah the jerkin
God otherwise known as Jerkins what do
we have here were you feeling sick no
thanks for asking Jerkins oh actually
like when you name people it seems to
autoc capitalize them when you name
things they can be anything oh I see hey
Jerkins jerkin there brilant Jerkins son
of
Jerkins and you oh we named Solitude to
Jerkins I just renamed the whole city
Jerkins Junior aside from renaming
everything Jerkins what you could do is
you could say go into your player home
pickpocket Jerkins on the way and you
could rename all of your different um
chests to be like ores and weapons and
things like that and now we are wielding
the sword of jerkin so like for renaming
items it's pretty great great you can
use it to kill Jerkins yep you could
take the head off Jerkins whoa Jerkins
Ste on girls Cal it's okay it's okay
we're going to ride out of here Jerkins
jerkin Spooks easily yes let's
[Music]
go careful careful wonderful Splash
Landing Jerkins so what's the name of
this next mod Seb okay the next mod is
called winter Mist enchantments of
Skyrim so this adds a bunch of new
enchantments to Skyrim correct it does
okay so it basically asks if we're bored
of the vanilla pool of just 34
enchantments because maybe we would want
104 new ones yes uh now this in this mod
doesn't make it easy for you it doesn't
simply add all of these enchantments to
your list you can't just pick a weapon
and enchant it with something magical
and new you have to find and disenchant
everything of these 104 they're roughly
split by the way half armor half weapons
all righty Serv we just added a few of
these new enchantments using console
commands so let's let's check them out
uh into our inventory we've got the
ebony MCE of disjunction that's a new
one racking Ruckus thwarting annoyance
irritation black ice decimation ghosts
ghosts and then Blood Sport word Jerkins
and mercy killings and Jerkins what
would you like to start with uh let's
start with a weapon I think okay so so
let's start with the disjunction that's
50% chance to dispel the target all
right we got a fire Mage with a with who
just cast some sort of um what's that
called again oh that's flame cloak
perfect oh perfect Des spel oh it's it
totally works and then killing and then
look you dis JK go what happened to
jerkens the horse where did jerkens the
horse go he was jerkens you coward ah
remove the fire cloak or I'll maybe just
remove your life there you go you yeah
you dispelled her kneecaps yeah yeah
really effectively and dispelled her
need for living did the horse the
Jerkins run overboard Jerkins Jerkins
it's you
ah oh God oh God it's Jerkins look who
it is I didn't think we'd see him today
but it's Jerkins um Robs a target of 10
gold pieces dealing 30 extra damage
that's cool come here I want gold ah
resisting
mug resist that 10% chance of striking
to gain invisibility for 5 seconds all
right let's just stab and just see what
happens stab make me invisible come on
oh God it dude you're so bad at this no
it was like it's a delay there we go ha
you'll never catch me now you'll never
know where I am I Kevin oh oh there
there I am power attacks deal 20% more
damage when break through enem block
that's cool let's give this a go
distracting noise I want to hear this
distracting
noise
what death is never SE so melodious
Nordic carve boots of trampling which is
going to stagger nearby enemies When
jumping yeah kill me we're just getting
richer and richer while we do
it goal added jump jump more jump jump I
say
stagger oh yes he fell over I think we
staggered him I heard it all right Seb
we should be able to use this Arcane
jerker that'll do enchant our sword of
jerkens sound and then maximum 50% Y and
then mug and mug also at 50% oh that is
going to be such a horrible weapon sord
of Jerkins here it is look lovely purple
en chants look how glowy it is creates a
distracting noise that makes spell
casting 50% harder for 10 seconds and
robs the target of up to 10 gold pieces
dealing an additional 37 extra damage in
the process if only there was a mod if
only there an enchantment that renamed
everything to Jerkins which you hit
that' be great it's cow it's cow we
better re rename him name cow cow
brilliant rename C to cow good job cow
you Jerkins kills you behold the sword
of
Jerkins all already said welcome to mod
number four and this week it's simply
called Sky cutter oo beautiful now uh
tell me a little bit about where this
mod comes from wait wait wait a minute
wait a minute y did you do this um I was
tidying I love it very neat I was kind
of thinking I could chuck them on the
cart and then maybe I could wheel them
out at a later date very nice bring out
your dead style bring out your dead you
want to go down to Dwarven as obviously
Sky Cutters are found in Dwarven and
there it is Sky cutter and we even have
all the bits we need look at it the
demons could not stand before the swords
of the Angelic host and their blood ran
upon the fields of Eternity Seb I reckon
is a sword it's from a different video
game What's it from it is from a
different video game that is the sword
you will have seen if you have either
played or seen the trailer for Diablo I
Reaper of Souls nice now is this a a
one-handed it is well then you know what
that means oh I think I do that means we
can make we can hold the sword of
Jerkins and Sky cutter actually that's
true I was just make two Sky Cutters but
yeah that's maybe even better so it's
got its own pretty effect right there in
the middle that makes it all Angelic
it's all gluey good for uh fighting off
Reapers of various things well Kevin in
a way is a Reaper of Souls he is I like
how the sword of Jerkins is just this
random iron like guard sword it's like
nothing special evil things to more
Lords they need to be oh wow that's
powerful wasn't expecting that yeah it
also removes heads and and this they
atomize oh it's a perfect one too he
jerkens him first watch watch jerkens oh
oh okay yeah straight in with the sky I
tried to jerkens him but jerkens jerkens
oh oh double doubled music and
dismemberment and then at the very end
of it oh wow they get turned to dust
anyway that's amazing that's fantastic
Sky Cutters great if only the uh
character at the beginning of the
trailer had two uh Sky Cutters he
probably would have been able to save
his friends yeah oh there he goes it is
really nice when we get to show off a
mod that's only one thing because it
means that you know somebody's maybe
been able to spend a bit more time on it
and make a like for like copy Sky cut is
good
but it's no sort of Jer sort of
jerkin love to abruptly cuts off oh
we're all covered in jamora blood
wonderful just how he wants
[Music]
it all right save time for the final mod
of today which is a user voted mod and
it's called
spectraverse Magic of the magn magn or
or whatever you want to go with
something like that I said g this is the
marker oh it looks at me it does does oh
it follows you around extra creepy
that's wonderful I am Kevin Van Nord I
am the marker created to explore and
Enlighten there will be me did he hear
that there will be me at the completion
of your journey there will be me Seb
yeah this this marker it appears to be
named
Jerkins amazing perfect must activate
additional pylons ah
wonderful this mod is already super I I
don't really get what we're meant to be
doing though start a quest then so this
this mod is founded on on a pretty broad
Quest and it's quite funny and it's it's
a really good Quest but uh the best part
of the whole thing is that as you
complete this Quest yeah you unlock a
bunch of
new spells what we should do is we'll
skip straight over to the awesome spells
s we got a mixed bag of enemies to
dispatch with these new spells so we
like all of them let's let's start with
a for abduct let's see what it does what
does abduct do I don't know there it
is
amazing and I guess you can just keep is
he just going to stay there you up you
go this is amazing let's have a look
up oh man just just hanging in thisy
they drop whoa yeah that's pretty great
that's look up what's it coming from oh
a black star no less beautiful another
one so you'll notice that some of them
are purple and some of them are blue
yeah in the quest story line you can
decide to go either of two factions yeah
if you go on the darker faction you get
all these purple spells and if you get
the go the lighter faction you get the
blue ones a bunch of these spells are
are ones that you have to use in
conjunction with one another so you
basically do like a setup spell and then
a follow-up spell and like the follow-up
won't do anything unless unless the
first one's been done so they're like
they buff each other I love Force
lightning it's so good all right this is
gravitation core I think this is going
to be a big one cuz it's a dual wielder
yes so it's going to bring it down
the oh wow amazing that is an awesome
spell that's
cool wow that's judgment that's really
good judgment's good oh wow that's
really really powerful Wormhole sorry
this is you're right this is Wormhole
oh this brought everything that was out
there and put it in a wormhole and then
and you're just shooting the hell out of
it with these oh I'm controlling that
amazing with these orbs of
light and um I guess he killed them all
first light it's another sh all right
here we go first
light
oh oh it's much the same zap zap zap zap
blasting it from space this is amazing
bears in
space these poor
we have to do Galactic finale at the end
hey troll Galactic finale it is I think
I've just taken the troll in oh no it's
up air as well hold still
friends whoa go on it's hard to shoot
them aim carefully aim
carefully and back down from space 30
explosive chickens I wonder what would
happen if we put them in a wormhole oh
that's science has often wondered this
question all right
chickens to the Wormhole oh no oh no
before we even made it what's going on
the chickens broke everything it's okay
now we know science has its
answer blow up yes yes exploding
chickens in
Sp can we summon more where are they oh
chick no they're not here that was
amazing well this is Wormhole chicken
there they
are gently does it gently does it and
off they go we're in space oh they're
going no way space nuke nuked it from
space with chickens we don't even know
what which way is up H that was amazing
it was so good that was everything I
prayed it would be oh fantastic Seb that
was everything I wanted from a chicken
explosion in space that that was more
than everything I wanted I knew what I
wanted and that was more than it which
was excellent a that was that's some of
the best moves we've had in a while well
chosen well chosen step forward what
happens when you get Cam and Seb on Sky
recommended as well Spectra verse was a
recommended mod so that was wonderful
awesome and speaking of your impact on
the show which is always awesome it's
time for questions and comments and
things like that and we actually
mentioned his first commenter earlier on
the show cat Jones is kind of the her
idea is the inspiration behind to Choose
Your Own Adventure Kevin vanord is going
to be fantastic and she asked us the
following question she said has there
ever been a point in Skyrim where you
have been truly lost or stuck on a quest
if so what was it or where was it um I'm
trying to remember I mean we've got
stuck Lots when doing like mod quests
mod quests you get stuck quite a lot
because they don't always make it
entirely obvious where you need to go
next the one that I always remember the
most mostly in Oblivion is when it would
say go to your next map marker and
continue on your quest you like there is
no map marker yes and you just have to
guess uh I'm going to throw in to the uh
to the pot here the stones of Baron zire
oh yeah that that's an awful Quest
that's just annoying it's it's one of
those like background quests but you
can't get rid of them you can't drop
them I love that one of the first ever
mods though that was ever created was
mat markers for all the locations of the
St what a brilliant what can't you fix
with mods nothing that's what nothing
and that's probably the best answer to
that question we can give exactly um
next up next up is a tweet from i hidden
crab who says who is your favorite
follower that isn't a human or a summon
um I'm going to throw mine in in as a
mod again yeah Inigo Inigo is great yeah
he's not a human he's a KET I guess I
really like U well you know I obviously
love DOA bear he's amazing DOA bear and
then there was that wolf we had recently
or that husky that we had I mean Lucy
Lola no not the invisible The Invisible
Dog no um me and Lucy Had A a husky
companion whose name I forget but they
were adorable so I don't know one of
those two awesome next up we've also had
a series of tweets um off the back of
Lucy invading the show this many times
yeah a series of images together that
sort of explains our relationship with
one another these are just these are
just the the Broman Hood so first up
we've got all three of us which is Lucy
you and me and we should say these are
all from Keith Duff field so thank you
at Bunny with a big bunny with a big gun
basically yeah uh so that that's what my
particular favorite is the Photoshop of
Lucy's face on Golem very very effective
uh second up of course bro Bromance Back
Mountain of me and you and I love how
unhappy you look at the fact that I'm
hugging you you're like oh God that's
the face I pull every time you hug me K
I didn't really want this to happen but
I guess we're hugging at the end of
every day of work and you're like I'll
see you tomorrow and you go for the hug
I'm like really again really that that's
a great face but this is my favorite
though the final is my favorite
definitely it's it's actually a really
good Photoshop and it makes me think
that we do look a little bit like our
namesakes there jez actually we really
do look a bit like Elijah would and you
look a bit like no it's only because
that's how your old hair used to be that
is exactly how my old hair used to be
it's amazing like it's like looking back
in the past it is uncanny how good that
photoshop is that's that's my favorite
by far wonderful world world work that
really is a Wonderful World what a time
to be alive Keith you have outdone
yourself sir that is a fantastic
fantastic Photoshop good job I didn't
think you'd get quite so much abuse set
and then but you know I got my
comeuppence when I was away like I
didn't checked Twitter for like a week I
just had a torrent of horrible
abuse me about my hairline I was like
incidentally there's nothing wrong with
my hairline oh yeah we were told to look
line is my line is fine it's more the
thinning of the slight thinning of the
hair slight he says um yeah smile all
this all this abuse I was like what yeah
so it was fine it was okay I I assume
that with every abusive tweet you
actually just just wanted to pass on
your love for me so thank you for that
very very everything you put in hate was
was caring yeah yeah thank you guys we
felt never felt so welcome okay final
one from NE Rigby Seb take it away I'm
almost 100% sure that the level's Tower
mod has been featured on the show before
and I was was right it was a much
earlier version of course and dang it
was back when sha McKinnis was hosting I
knew I remembered it see what happens
when I'm not here se you redo old mods I
just I'm throwing in stuff from the old
pop but that's um yeah it it has been
upgraded since so you know don't feel
too bad about it and you could say that
the show has been upgraded since not
that the show wasn't great before
because it was Sean and John did a great
job they did yes but uh but yes it's
quite a different show now so I figure
we can we can showcase some more as well
I'm going to pretend it was deliberate
yeah that that was deliberate I was late
okay but Seb yes that is the end of the
of the user comments great interaction
thanks so much for sending all those
comments in and for all the abuse phot
the photoshops were amazing but it's
time for the mod vote I love this part
so my favorite part of the show so Seb
what what is what do we have what is
what are R number one is uh vote in
second place silver medal vote from last
week white white runs well Reb I did
this last week I can't say well rebor I
do it white runs well reborn I
apparently am the only one who can't say
this cuz Lucy nailed it first time you
were like oh what a tongue twister and
she nailed it and you're like shut up
whatever and next cam who have we got
we've got unlocked grip or what have we
got rather is interesting sure what that
it is a uh a mod that's going to change
the way you can interact with one-handed
and two-handed weapons I like it I like
it and finally resale vampire armor this
is armor by the way from Soul rebirth
back on the PS1 I I remember playing
this game Legacy of Kane yes the First
Legacy of Kane game that came on to um
the PlayStation one I even played the
original Legacy of Kane which I forget
the name of it blood something and that
was on pal that was on the Mega Drive I
think I played that yeah great game
there you go well if that's something
you want to see then you can vote for it
how would you do it well Seb you go to
Tiny URL I'll try again well Seb you go
to tinyurl.com
ready sebie blog and that's where you
can cast your vote on the straw pole
that's there interestingly we will be
setting up another blog maybe Cam's blog
uh to do the future yes Choose Your Own
Adventure and it's going to be
tinyurl.com
camr blog that actually already exists I
know but but it links to my blog so it's
perfect it we haven't got one yet no but
it will be the first one it will be the
first one yes all right SE so how do
people actually submit their first lines
for the Kevin vanord Choose Your Own
Adventure let's keep it simple let's say
your first entry into the Choose Your
Own Adventure Quest needs to fit into a
tweet good idea it to us uh send it to
one of in fact if you want to save
yourself some extra space just put um #g
Skyrim and don't send it to either of us
that's true and we can find it there
tell us the opening to your story and we
will pick the first five well the five
best and then we will put them in for
the votes and that is how this whole
Adventure is going to begin yes and
don't forget as well you need to tweet
us to let us know if you would come and
see us live in London you got you got a
lot of work to do guys a lot of homework
so you got to you got to vote on The Mod
for now week you got to tweet us with
your suggestions and whether or not you
want us to do a live thing in in London
and you've also got to get writing on
the initial sentence in part of the
Kevin vanor choose your adventure so you
get cracking there aot work to be done
let said speaking of a lot of work we
are about to go and do a live stream by
the time this episode is live on
Gamespot we will also be live we will be
live on
twitch.tv Gamespot or gamespot.com chat
now if you are watching on YouTube and
that stream probably over just about
just about over our part will be
certainly but I think you'll be able to
catch it on um the archive version on
Twitch if you really want to do 100
hours 100 games extra life raising
hopefully Char for the children $20,000
for the children is our is our Target
yeah for the children so wish us luck
I'm going to be in my pajamas I brought
them in from home they have pirates that
means we can we can be future Amo quotes
and say well I am already in my pajamas
I am already that's the only quot that's
the only thing I'm going to say say all
the time but anyway Sky mods another
week done thanks so much Seb that was
great show hope you guys enjoyed it let
us know what you think of the new things
we're doing send us your all your stuff
that we've asked for and we'll see you
back here next
[Music]
week